hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing with the match Magnus
Carlsen versus Yanni polishing and well
now we left it off at Game three Game
three was won by Magnus who equalized
the match after blundering that piece in
seven in Game one and Game four in their
match ended in a draw so here we are in
Armageddon and the Magnus human the coin
toss and he chose the white pieces so he
says that he's ready to win the game to
win the match which means if you're new
to the 2d or this whole Armageddon thing
that Magnus has five minutes nipple gets
four but Magnus needs to win and if the
game is drawn then Knepper wins the
match so let's check it out Magnus opens
with d4 and we have Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 g6 end now Bishop
to f4 so Magnus goes again for his
London system we have Bishop to g7 and
Knight B to d2 and therefore castles in
the now c3 yeah we have b6 and h3 now
and the c5 by napal striking in the
center and of course if you know you're
facing Magnus you you do look up the
London system with black so D captures
on c5 and the D captures on c5 I think
it was a in in the last world world
blitz championship where and Carlsen
defeated the Vladimir Kramnik
with white with London system Kramnik
said in an interview after the game that
the London system isn't anything I mean
it's nothing it's it doesn't give white
anything but it's just when you play
against Magnus it's it's a different
story
so Magnus sticks to is a London system
we have d captures on c5 and now efore
we have Knight to c6 and the Bishop to
e2 preparing the castle never-was b6
prepare stuff in care to the light
square bishop and now comes just castles
by white and Bishop to b7 which is a new
move in the position so already as of
move 11 we have a completely new game
Magnus continues with rook to e1 I just
continues development once the bishop
moves the rook will be useful along the
e-file and the Queen to d7 I'll never
develop the Queen connects rooks
prepares rook a to d8
we have Queen to c2 Magnus does the same
and now of course rook a to d8 Magnus
also brings the rook into the game and
now Quinta CA to getting the Queen Oh
from from this rooks grasp
we have 'if I've now just kicking away
that night Knight to d5 and Bishop to g3
and night the c7 now by nipple
we have Quinta a for now Magnus prepares
to shift the Queen over to the Kings
side to help out with the attack and
night to e6 now we have Queen to h4 and
Bishop to a6 now never wants the trade
off the lights for bishops and then if
Magnus ever moves the knight then trade
off both pairs of rooks along the D file
so Bishop captures an a6 magnet straight
once and now Quinta efore saying you do
not get the capture the a dupont as your
knight is under attack
so Knepper goes back queen b7 and now
Knight to c4 by Magnus it is in fact
Magnus who offers up trades along the D
file so nipple very happy to trade
everything he only needs a draw to win
the match characters captures and of
course rook the d8 and Magnus trades we
have capture son b8 Knight see capture
sandy 8 and now Queen captures and b7 so
even trading Queens we have night
capture son b7 and now a for not
allowing b5 and here both players are of
course very low on time as they were
very long time when the game started so
here they have to play an entire endgame
of course being a very long time so both
players start improving the position of
their kings King f1 obviously its net
was mu soaking afraid the King to f1 and
the King to e8 with King the e2 King to
d7 and now King to d3 and night beat d8
preparing to shift the night over to c6
we have night to g1 making room for the
f4 pawn to help out with the defense of
the e5 pawn so nice to see 6 the
attacking the pawn in King Teti for
defending once again we have h5 by nepo
and now f4 now that the point is nice
the defendant the bishop can again be
activated now and here nipple just goes
f5 with check and here if this was any
sort of a normal game of classical game
or something like that you probably go
back or something like this but Magnus
needs a win to win the match so he has
to go forward so it captures an f6 ALPA
song we have P captures on f6 and now f5
just further going forward we have
Knight to g5 with check King to be three
ended now only now G captors an f5 so
Magnus sacrificed the pawn but he didn't
mess up Naples pawn structure and well
he he keeps the chances alive we have
night the e3 going after the f5 pawn in
the Nippo defense at night to the e7 and
now tonight's the e2 you start bringing
the other night into the game 96 and now
King to c4 so hoping for king b5 King e6
and you start to gobbling up these pawns
but King to c6 of course neppo doesn't
allow it but before now Magnus again
continues his march forward we have C
captures and V for seek actress and now
Bishop the age sex putting pressure on
the night here but first we have b5 with
checks so Magnus grabs more space we
have King to d7 and now Knight to d5
offering a trade here to improve the
position of his king a year again so net
portrait Knight capture skin captures
Magnus slowly making progress but nipple
not worried as well he's up upon and it
is it is a pretty equal ish in game so
f4 trying to close Magnus is Bishop with
Bishop to F 2 nd now Bishop back to f8
controlling that c5 square we have nice
to d4 and now Knight to c5 not not going
for this straight as then black would
have to worry about these pawns on the
King side so Knepper prefers not to
trade this knife to c5 instead he goes
for the a4 pawn and you cannot defend it
so instead Magnus goes for the a7 point
and here we start grabbing Knight
captures Knight captures and now Knight
to c3 with check King to see for kicking
away the night Knight to d1 attacking
the bishop and now Bishop captures and
b6 so here Magnus grabs back the pond
and it's again equal material but it's
Magnus with the past be pawn but nipple
still not worried just Knights the e3
with Czech threatening to capture the g2
point and create a passed pawn of his
own so here at Magnus decides the
capture we have Bishop captures and pawn
captures and now Knepper also has a very
very strong passport so King the three
and now Bishop c5 defending and
attacking here Magnus has to go
somewhere else with an
Knight to c6 and now King to d6 we have
Knight to a5 and now King the e5 of
course bringing the King over to help
out with the defense of the past pawn
king e2 and now King to f4 by nipple and
here Knight to c4 we have kink the g3
now or hoping to gobble up all of these
pawns which would be which would be very
nice and just Knight captures on e3
which defends the pawn here and also you
cannot trade because then well you just
can't stop the promotion of the b-pawn
so h4 by Napo and now King to d3 by
Magnus now Magnus enjoys this position
he now wants to further improve his
position brush up to a seventh nipple
has to wait and King to e4 but now nepo
finds the very interesting f5 with check
point is that if King captures then the
shop just grabs the night so Magnus has
the capture with the knight this comes
with check but now he's no longer
defending the g2 pawn we have captures
here cross and captures with check in
the nipple captures on h3 so this is
just one huge capture fest of a game
which ends with this night against
bishop with Magnus having a passport the
problem is an epic and whenever Magnus
pushes the point even if the point is
protected you can just give it up and
the Magnus left with only a knight
cannot achieve more than a draw but the
problem is both players are below 1
minute on the clock
and there is no increment here so it's
flagging time so Knight to f5 by Magnus
we have King to g4 by neppo Knight to e7
we have King g5 nipple will now try to
shift his King over to the Queen side to
help out defending and king te 5 cutting
off the black ink we have king to h6 and
now King to e6
we have King to g7 and now Knight to c8
going after the bishop
we have Bishop back to f2 in the now
Knight to d6 like I said you cannot push
because the black just captures it and
it's a draw by insufficient material so
night study 6 and the now came to f8 we
have King to d7 and bish of the g1 just
keeping an eye on the b6 square we have
Knight to e4 King to f7 and now comes
King to c6 by Magnus we have Kings the
e7 and now Knight the c5 blocking off
the bishop so you can start pushing your
pawn so
Knepper goes King the eighth this gives
him a moment bring his skin closer to
the passport now b6 and now shifting
your Bishop over to this diagonal to
keep an eye on the BH square so b7 and
now comes the shop the b8 just saying
this is a draw there's nothing you can
do here
we have night the a6 by Magnus going
after that there should be just a bishop
back to f4 we have Knight back the c5 by
Magnus and the nipple repeats Bishop to
b8 and now a Magnus of course would
agree to a draw here if it was a normal
game but it's not so he has to try at
least at least hope the neighbor will
blunder or try and flag him so Knight
the e6 check King to e7 and now Knight
the c7 yeah so again nothing much going
on here never repeats King d8 and now
Knight to d5 and Knepper just goes back
bush up to g3 we have Knights the f6 by
Magnus further trying to create some
complications nepo just keeps his Bishop
on this diagonal Bishop h2 and the
Knights the--for and here is the moment
where well many a player would go wrong
but the point is you have to go to
something like Bishop the c7 the problem
is you cannot go bash up the b8 and it's
it's impossible to know these things I
guess unless you you're a real student
of the endgame but point is you have to
go back up to c7 so when I move like
night c5 lands then you go bash up the
b8 and then you're very happy here
there's no way for for the night to do
anything once 96 check you're gonna move
the king and still the white king cannot
cannot approach or anything and well 97
doesn't really block the bishop as the
bishop is already on b8 however never
played Bishop the b8 here and it's it's
a valid plan you just go back that's the
plan that's how you draw well not
exactly because here Magnus went night
to c5 and now you have problems because
if the bishop was here and now you would
shift it to be 8 and now it would be ok
but here it's sort of a tempo trick
because here if you play with the King
let's say King e8 now you go Knight the
a6 and now if you go back then just
Knight the c7 and the bishop no longer
controls ba so you have to go here but
now there's actually a technique how to
how to win this King c7 you go kink the
e7 now Knights to be 4 you're going to
the bishop back from there so King e6
and now Knight to c6 so Bishop has to go
back Bishop to c5 and of course now if
you queen you will still draw because a
bishop check picks up the Queen
so first King to see it again you give
black a move Bishop to d6 keeping an eye
on the square here now Knight the d4
check your gonna go King to d5 and now
Knights to b5 attacking the bishop and
now when the King is here guarding the
b8 squared the bishop has to go back
wherever and now you just block it with
check and next move your queen so that's
the problem if the King moves so nepo
tried Bishop back to h2 which of course
makes sense but here Magnus just played
night the e6 with check and it was in
this position unmoved 79 that young
opponent should resign the game and
Magnus wins the match in Armageddon
which means he only gets two points and
nipple gets is one point but it also
means that Magnus is definitely going to
the well later part of the competition
to the knockout stage as he is now
definitely in the top four whereas for
napal napal can no longer qualify for
the top four in this tournament but
we're gonna discuss the standings a bit
more tomorrow after well the other half
of the participants play out their games
so here you resign because well after
this check your you have to move the
King and after the King moves now ninety
seven just blocks blocked the bishops
retreat here so really in just an
amazing position this you should
remember it and show it to your friends
at the bar in the library you know once
they once they open up you know just
just a remarkable like this is a
complete draw Bishop c7 rosebush should
be eight losses it's incredible stuff
but yeah now Magnus again wins and it's
a question did Magnus just stumble into
this end game and then well just got a
win as nepo blundered or did Magnus know
that well in a very short time controls
that it's almost impossible to hold this
with Bishop against a knight and pawn so
that's that's the real question here but
yeah that's the game I'd hope you
enjoyed it I will I would like to thank
Robin random earth we are Tilly and the
Bailey Warren for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it ends so thank you
all I will see you soon and have
excellent rest of your day